all I could say as I loved his monologue
sarah silverman weighing in on X Jimmy
Kimmel's emotional monologue about his
newborn son who was born with a heart
condition
you know before 2014 if you were born
with congenital heart disease like my
son was there was a good chance you'd
never be able to get health insurance
because he had a pre-existing condition
if your baby is going to die and it
doesn't have to it shouldn't matter how
much money you make I think that's
something now whether you're a
Republican or Democrat or something else
we all agree on that Ryan I mean we do I
love those last couple minutes when he
made a very bipartisan plea to keep
funding things like Children's Hospital
and the stuff that is getting cut right
now is affecting children born with
diseases and I thought he was beautiful
and eloquent and my heart is with him
and Molly Sarah battled her own health
condition last year a rare throat
disease that she says nearly killed her
you know when you almost die feel like
you're gonna like come out of it and be
like have a really genius perspective
but all I really learned is we're
ticking time bombs et caught up with the
comedian at who's upfront presentation
in New York City where she was promoting
her new show I Love You America I've
been wanting to do a show more about
social politics we are very divided and
I just feel like all we really need to
do is be a little bit more one-on-one
and get our porcupine needles down and
realize that we're the same
you